the world of Pokemon is a bright
colorful place full of unusual animals
and if you're anything like the average
gamer you've spent hundreds of hours
wandering through the wilderness looking
for Pocket Monsters to fight kidnap and
train to battle for you it's a vicious
cycle and that underlying weirdness has
given rise to some of the strangest
creepiest video game bootlegs and mods
of any series out there after seeing
these Pokemon bootlegs we're not sure if
you'll want to catch em all Pokemon
creepy black the bizarre rumor of
pokemons creepy black first popped up
around 2005 when someone supposedly
found an all-black Gameboy cart at a
flea market the game gives you the
option to start out with your standard
Pokemon but you can also start out with
ghosts a Pokemon that can do only one
thing
instantly terrify other pokemons and
trainers to death by the end of the game
your trusty ghost turns on you and you
two are dragged into the cold cold
ground as with most online horror
stories Pokemon creepy black probably
wasn't a legit kart but the weird
Internet story inspired multiple modders
to bring the game to life in ROM form
download it if you'd like a sleepless
night or two pondering the ethics of
being a pokemon trainer just watch out
for those ghost types the creepy doesn't
stop there however Hypno's lullaby a mod
that arose from a creepypasta poem
Hypno's lullaby is all about the strange
hypnotic pokemon and his secret penchant
for kidnapping small children and
bringing them to his cave and berry
forest one could argue that every single
Pokemon deserves a bit of revenge for
how they're treated by their trainers
and Hypno's lullaby exacts that revenge
tenfold your hero really has no option
but to grab a starter Pokemon and wander
into the woods where you're immediately
captured by hypno and trapped in a cave
with other zonked out kids as you work
your way out of the cave you can only
order your Pokemon to kill Hypno's
juvenile slaves who block every exit
then you work your way through a tower
full of unbeatable ghosts and the
spirits of children you've killed
eventually hypno throws one last barrage
of children at you before trapping you
in a room where he eats your dreams for
all eternity
there is no end you
shut off the game and quietly walk away
telling no one what you've done there is
even more for you however if you like
your pokemons full of death and despair
Pokemon snakewood pokemon ruby is a
popular Pokemon game to mod and Pokemon
snakewood is just one strange example of
the results snake wood crosses Pokemon
with the walking dead
the results is a game in a
post-apocalyptic setting populated by
zombies and demons where even the
pokemon have adorably creepy names like
polly wraith and head doom in true
Walking Dead style your hero wakes up in
a destroyed town encounter someone being
attacked by zombies and finds a safe
zone as you play you eventually battle
the Four Horsemen of the Apocalypse
which is a lot scarier than just
battling some spoiled kid who likes
forcing animals to fight one another
it's a surprisingly robust story for an
unofficial game snakewood proves that
Pokemon has its fair share of inventive
and weird fans Pokemon courts do you
love the concept of Pokemon but hate all
of those corporate Nintendo approved
monsters well Pokemon courts may be the
game for you dedicated Pokemon
bootleggers made a copy of Ruby and
replaced all of the official Pokemon
sprites with their own malformed
creations while these Pocket Monsters
names and appearances have changed their
powers and stats remain intact why have
the charm Anders been replaced with
these our best scientists are still
working on an answer quartz is
criticized for being relatively
amateurish and incomplete but the visual
overhaul of so many lovable and popular
Pokemon is just so weirdly obsessive and
pointless that it can't be ignored
Pokemon suite modded from firered
Pokemon suite reimagines the entire
world of Pokemon as a surreal Candy
Kingdom like place here everything is
made of desserts and delicious danger
lurks around every corner because just
walking around cotton candy fields isn't
enough your favorite Pokemon now called
pokey sweets are now named after snacks
Bulbasaur becomes brownie sore and gets
a dollop of whipped cream and a cherry
and pops a chew has a giant wooden stick
shoved into its head Pokemon types are
now flavours instead and you basically
just ruined your dinner the deadliest
attack in the game diabetes
vuillemin emerald fire red for those who
want their pokemon experience to be even
weirder mo Amon is for you
Molly maan replaces all of those totally
unattractive monsters with sprites of
cosplay girls dressed up as Pokemon
instead raising even more ethical
questions than the original because
pitting animals in death matches against
one another isn't horrifying enough you
now send costume girls into the arena to
fight one another until one finally
passes out from the pain instead of
building your pokemons collection you
slowly grow a violent confusing little
harem pokémon ash gray true pokey nerds
know the differences between the
original Pokemon games and the anime of
the same name ash gray inventively
tweaks the original game script and
missions to actually follow the events
of the offshoot media including many
episode specific events from giving
Donuts to primates to leaving Pikachu to
live with other Pikachu in the forest
the results is a carton of Easter eggs
for devotees of the Pokemon universe who
may have found the original games
lacking after seeing the more colorful
anime if the cartoon isn't your thing
however there are even more options for
players who want something more out of
Pokemon than just grinding for gangers
Pokemon advanced adventure as far as
narrative structure goes the Pokemon
anime series is still pretty flimsy ash
doesn't have any real motivation to be
the best pokemon trainer in the world
aside from the fact that it's something
to do in a world without standardized
education or non Pokemon based
employment opportunities Pokemon
advanced adventure flips the script and
rewrites Ash as a kid struggling against
poverty genetically modified Pokemon and
Professor Oak's insane tyrannical
grandson whose only purpose is to Train
pokemons to kill finally ash is written
as an actual hero and not just some
animal hoarder with dozens of neglected
pets pokemon vietnamese crystal while
most of these games are intentionally
strange there are also a few examples
that are amazing by accident like
pokemon vietnamese crystal fake pokemon
cards are a huge business and kotake
reports that this was a genuine bootleg
that circulated in vietnam before it was
poorly translated
to English as a result the games text is
hilarious it regularly drops profanity
calls pokemon elves and barely attempts
to make sense since it's just a
mistranslated Pokemon game without any
big changes it plays just fine if you
can make the right text selections
through the garbled menus and figure out
what the game means by phrases like
volcano baked meat which kind of sounds
exactly like something Guy Fieri would
serve 2003 pocket monster carbuncle
unlike most pokemons bootlegs which just
tweak existing code 2003 pocket monster
carbuckle actually attempts some
originality according to a geek party
review the resulting game plays a bit
like the classic NES Dragon Warrior but
also reduces the number of Pokemon to 20
tossing biodiversity out the window the
word carbuncle usually refers to a
cluster of boils which would be
appropriate enough for this game but
it's also an obscure word for a red
gemstone which fits in with pokemons
recurring theme of naming games after
fancy rocks
unfortunately 2003 pocket monster
carbuncle is a garbage game and it
doesn't play like Pokemon in any sense
whatsoever but points for trying
something new unknown foreign plagiarize
errs Pocket Monsters Go Go Go now we
enter the realm of the truly terrible
for no reason whatsoever other than to
dupe unsuspecting Pokemon fans some
horrible soul switched out sprites from
the Smurfs nightmare for Game Boy Color
made it run at half speed and pretended
it was a Pokemon game even the most
lonely fanfic writers never asked for a
Smurfs Pokemon crossover but anything is
possible when you have no friends
starting off your adventure you're
greeted by a talking Meowth head who
rambles the following every night in my
dreams I see you I feel you you are here
so I very fear there is some hate that
will not go away then you send your
morbidly obese Pikachu through some kind
of Satan town with flickering
seizure-inducing backgrounds you then
quickly pull the card out of your
Gameboy and throw it across the room
before it's too late
Pokemon Stadium super nintendo addition
despite pokemons relentless popularity
there was never an official game made
for the original Nintendo Entertainment
System or the Super Nintendo in fact the
first
major Pokemon game for consoles was the
Nintendo 64 is pokemon stadium so it
makes little sense to reverse-engineer
an n64 cartridge to an older gaming
system the SNES was pretty outdated by
this time so making bootlegs of
imaginary games wasn't really
economically viable it's like trying to
sell a fake dial-up modem even if it's
real
no one needs one anymore much like the
real pokemon stadium the SNES bootleg is
a turn-based fighter but with a limited
roster of 12 Pokemon they all have
incorrect names
Diglett as daggits Mewtwo is Moo and
Jigglypuff is : it's a fully functional
game unlike most bootlegs but it's a
step in the wrong direction just like
the final game in our list pokemons four
and one another relic from the age of
the original Nintendo Pokemon foreign
one is one of those terrible anthology
games that crams for games onto a card
to apologize for all of them sucking and
again because the nintendo entertainment
system was becoming a thing of the past
by the time Pokemon was popular this is
just weird the game includes pika click
where you click on groups of matching
symbols pika dance where you tap on
pokeballs in time to a song peak a slot
which is a slot machine for amateur
gamblers and pac-man which is pac-man
but with a disembodied Pikachu head
every single aspect of this is a waste
of money and time but because it's
bizarre and obscure fogey collectors
will sell their pokey kidneys to get
their hands on one thanks for watching
subscribe to our YouTube channel to
watch more videos like the one you just
saw and leave us a comment to let us
know which bootleg Pokemon game you
think is the weirdest